okay so thank you for the kind kind
introduction and thanks for having me my
name is Gabor SES I work at Duck DB Labs
as a developer relations Advocate and
I'm here to talk about duck DB which
brings the power of a data warehouse in
your python process so first a very
brief introduction I come from Academia
I studied in Hungary and did a PhD in
software engineering in the Technical
University of Budapest and I slowly
drifted towards datadriven topics data
engineering and building data processing
systems so in 2020 I moved to the
Netherlands and I moved to an Institute
called CWI which does research on
database systems maybe CWI is not very
well known outside of Europe it is
actually the birthplace of python so
it's a very nice connection to this
event python was created there in
1989 I was part part of the database
group and the database group was the one
which created this system called duck DB
which I will talk about today so duck DB
is now backed by a company called duck
DB Labs which is also located in
Amsterdam we are a small startup of
about 15 16 people and we work on the
development of duck DB and we provide
commercial support services for duck
DB so just to get an idea of your
familiarity here who here has heard
about duck DB
before that is one two hands and who has
used duck DB before that's zero hands
okay so I think I can tell you some
information about this system so the
context of this is the field of dat
science which is a relatively new field
and has been very popular in the last 10
to 15 years or so this figure shows what
is called a data science workflow which
starts by asking an interesting question
you have a problem domain and you want
to answer some sort of an interesting
question that you think will help your
business or it will help your
research once you have this question of
course you need some data to back it up
that's why it's called data science so
data comes in all shapes of forms you
have CSV files Park files Json files you
often have binary formats and you get
these data sets you load them in a
system explore them and then once you
have explored them maybe you build some
machine learning model on it maybe you
create a visualization with matplot Li
plotly and so on and this is iterative
so you keep repeating it you pose more
questions and you try to extract more
and more value from the data and we
would like to focus on the middle part
exploring the data this is difficult to
do from an integration perspective
because you have all the different data
formats that you need to handle and it's
also difficult because it's
computationally challenging to process
large amounts of data not to mention
that once you have finished exploring
the data you need to pass it on the next
layer in some format that those
libraries like pytorch tensor flow and
the others can
consume so there are a couple of choices
for exploring data and I think you have
already used a few of these options
before the go-to option for most data
scientists is to use data frame
libraries pandas is very well known in
the python community and polers is also
a popular new choice for working on data
frames the problem here especially in
the case of pandas is that it has severe
performance limitations pandas is
running on a single thread so running
queries takes a long time loading takes
a long time and these systems don't
really have query optimizers so the data
scientist is left on their own to
formulate their problems in API Calles
that you stitch together in a lazy
Manner and then evaluate it once these
systems tend to run out of memory if you
have uh quite complex problems and when
pandas runs out of memory that's when
most data scientists switch to something
like spark or dusk which are distributed
computing systems so here you can run
multiple computers and you will not run
out of memory but you will have the
burden of configuring that cluster
paying for that cluster and operating
that cluster not to mention that even if
you have all this done it indeed scales
but it has a big performance impact and
even for Middle siiz data sets it can be
slower than what you would expect from a
large cluster of
computers and finally we have data
warehouses which on the surface look
like the perfect choice these are
database systems that are geared towards
analytics they have very sophisticated
query engines so in principle they would
be excellent for taking data ingesting
it and exploring it quickly the problem
is that they are also quite difficult to
operate they can be very expensive to
license because most of these are
proprietary systems and it is difficult
to get the data in the data warehouse
and then get the data out of the data
warehouse for future use like plotting
and machine learning so we think there
is room for improvement in this box of
exploring data and hence we created duck
DB in a nutshell duck DB is an
analytical SQL database so it has the
sophisticated architecture of a data
warehouse but it is made for data
scientists to be easy to use it has been
developed since 2018 it's written
entirely in C++ 11 and it has no
external dependencies so it is very
portable and it has been gaining
popularity quite a lot in the python
word we have more than 1.5 million
downloads a month on the pii Repository
a question that you might naturally ask
why is it called duck DB well in
Amsterdam we have many canals and people
often live on a boat so one of our
co-founders hes lived on a boat and
wanted a pet and he picked a duck
because a duck is of course a very
practical animal to have on a boat
because it can swim and is not afraid of
water at all so this is hanus and his
pet duck wibur duck DB was named in the
honor of
wibur
so the rest of the talk I will talk
about duck DB's unique features and what
makes it work and how does it work key
among these is that it is an inprocess
database which may need a bit of
explanation so traditionally in the
database word and in the data warehouse
word you have a client server setup you
have the database server on the right
and you have some client application on
the left and this is often quite
challenging to deal with first you have
to set up a database you can maybe run
it in a cloud or run it on premises on a
server but you have to configure this
database you have to create users and
then you have to continuously run it or
start it when it's necessary once you
have that user you have to authenticate
so you have to set up the client
application with the correct address to
the database the correct user and the
correct password this is all very
tedious and even if you do all this you
will be limited by this little line in
the between which is the client protocol
which makes it necessary to take the
data that you have in your local process
and transfer it to the remote database
especially if you deal big data sets and
you pass tables back and forth this can
be very limiting on
performance the other problem is that
it's difficult to ingest data if you
have your input sources like the CSV
files on your local machine then you
have to push it through the client
protocol if you have it on the server
then you have to somehow address those
database data files and uh it's all very
tedious to get the data there so again
this is a problem so what duck DB does
is that it rethinks this architecture
and says how about taking the database
and bringing it into the client
application that's why we call it in
process because it runs in the client
application process you can see that the
code shrunk by quite a lot because we no
longer need to address authenticate or
do any of that setup we just say we
connect to this database the database is
now a single file on the disk that
contains all your tables and all your
data and then you can start running your
queries so it also makes it simpler to
just injust the CSV files because it's
obvious that you have a single machine
and you have the CSV files there and you
have the application and the database
all running on that machine of course
this impress thing is not entirely new
if we take a look at a categorization of
the database systems you can spot that
SQL light which is a very popular
embedded SQL database is on the top left
corner under in
process so why don't we use site for
data science well the thing is that
sqlite is geared towards what we call
transactional workloads transactional
workloads are heavy in wres and they
typically run queries that only touch on
small portions of the data so sqlite is
an excellent choice if you need to save
some configuration if you need to just
write some uh cookies down for your
browser Etc but it doesn't really work
for data science where you have
gigabytes of data frames that you have
to crunch over and over again to get
some information out of it so duck DB is
currently the only system that we are
aware of that sits in the top right
under impr process and
analytical duck DB is a free system this
is very important because a lot of the
issues with using database Management
systems and data warehouses is that they
are expensive and also having a license
is more complicated than not having a
license it can be tricky to set up those
systems and adding a license file uh so
duck DB is an open source system you can
go on GitHub is distributed under the
very permissive MIT license so you can
Fork it you can create your own version
of duck DB you can use it internally
this is all Allowed by the
license tdb is also free in the sense
that you do not need to run a server you
do not need to pay for a cloud instance
or any other things like that dgdb is
capable of doing relatively large data
processing tasks just on your laptop it
turns out that the laptops in the last
10 to 15 years have developed a lot so
most of them have more than four CPU
cores they have reasonably fast discs
and they have quite a lot of memory so
you can get a long way with a
laptop du DB is fast this is of course
very important if you do uh data science
but how can it be so fast how come none
of the other systems do this well the
trick is to a large extent in the data
layout so I mentioned that we have
transactional systems which are right
heavy and the queries typically access
only a small amount of the data for
these systems uh something called a row
storage or row based layout is the ideal
one this allows individual rowes to be
fetched very cheaply so the system can
just Target a single data point and get
all the attributes that that data has so
this is great for some workloads but if
we have a different workload where we
are only interested in the values of a
few columns which is very typical in
data science then uh this is wasteful so
we have something called columnar data
storage for that that's already used by
data warehouses and of course also duck
DB here the data is stored by column on
the disk and we can fetch individual
columns so if someone asks what if
you're only interested in the price of a
product but we don't care about dates
and store and the customer well then we
can skip scanning 60% of the data and
this leads to immense Savings in terms
of dis IO and memory not to mention that
if we store the data based on the column
we will have data that is very similar
as we scan it on the disk so if we have
a date column the date doesn't really
change that much between two subsequent
values of the same column so we can use
uh heavy
compression let's walk through an
example suppose we have a one terab
table with 100 columns and we have a
quer that only requires five of these
columns to be evaluated if we do a row
based representation we have to go
through the entire one tbte of the data
at a disk speed of 100 megabytes which
is reasonable for a fast HDD this will
take 3 hours but if you use columnar
storage it goes down to just 50 gabyt
which can be done in approximately 8
minutes and this is before compression
because if we use compression then we
can save approximately 3 to 5x
further um size of the data here is
actually a very nice history of how this
was improved in Duck DB so initially
duck DB did not have compression and
then we added various compression
methods like run length encoding bit
packing dictionary and new compression
methods that the team in Amsterdam has
invented and based from no compr ression
we went to a 5x saving on uh some data
which is from The tpch
Benchmark so if we continue the example
that uh we have done in uh the slide
before we can go down from roughly 8
minutes of scanning to uh just one
minute and 40 seconds so we have saved
roughly 100x on scanning the data and
getting it into the quer engine for
processing that is of course a quite
significant difference the other
significant difference is the query
execution method so the seite system and
the other systems with uh transactional
processing use something called tle at a
time meaning they process one row at a
time pandas does column at a time and
Doug DB uses vectorized processing I
will explain these through examples so
in tole at the time processing we
optimize for having low memory footprint
this is very important because these
systems come from an age where memory
was at a premium so you can run very
complex queries by only keeping a single
Row in memory and the related
intermediate results the problem is that
this has a very high CPU overhead so if
you have millions of rows to go through
then you will have that overhead times a
million and in turn your query
processing will be very slow your CPU
will be constantly forc to switch
context and this is just not efficient
for data science workloads a better
approach is the column at a time
approach this is used by pandas so it
takes one column and it takes the other
column and it runs them through the
operators that you define the problem
here is that it takes an entire column
at once so it has to materialize large
intermediate data sets in memory and
that can measure to gigabytes or larger
each and this can get you out of memory
exceptions so this will cause your uh
system to crash if you select two large
data
sets so the ideal solution is somewhere
in the middle We should strive to use
some sort of a column n processing but
limit the size and not take an entire
column net and there are techniques for
that it's called vectorized processing
it basically means that to take a chunk
of the columns and manage to put that
through the query process this allows
you to have good CPU locality and it
allows you to also use something called
single instruction multiple data which
are built-in instructions in modern CPUs
that allow you to process multiple data
items at once with a single CPU
instruction so you get a lot of built-in
parallelism even if you just run on a
single
thread so this is the best approach to
exploit the modern CPU architecture
which is actually quite complicated and
has huge differences between latency in
the CPU cache like L1 L2 and the main
memory you can see in the example here
that there is also 100x difference here
in terms of the latency for the L1 cache
and the main memory so duck DB exploits
that and tries to formulate the queries
in a way that you can keep them in the
L1
cache of course this is very challenging
to Port between different computer
architectures because different computer
architectures have slightly different
CPU instructions more on that
later finally one strong point of duck
DB is that it has all the bells and
whistles of a data warehouse it can take
expressions in queries and rewrite them
to more efficient forms it can reorder
the joins in the queries it can flatter
subqueries and it can do filter and
projection push Downs these are things
that pandas can also do but this is
automatic induct DB and manual imp
pandas so we can run queries quickly we
can store the data quickly but can we
load the data quickly well thankfully
dug DB has a highly optimized parallel
CSV loader uh and we believe this is
very important because data science is
ultimately an interactive sort of genre
you sit in front of the computer and you
don't want to grab another coffee every
time you load a new data set so I
prepared a little demo with a synthetic
social network Benchmark data set which
is available online so let's see how
this works we have a directory record
person so this is the social network and
the people in the network if we read
into the file we can see that it's
called a CSV file but it's not actually
comma separated it has pipes as the
separators and it has fields that you
would expect from a social network
people have names and genders and
birthdays and email addresses so we can
roughly see that each line in the CSV
file corresponds to an individual person
in the network so let's see how this
looks like if we want to get this to
pund us so I will first run this query
and then explain what it does so here we
take the person directory and go through
the CSV files we explain pandas that
there's a pipe separator in the file and
then we concatenate all these files
after each other and we get the final
data frame that encodes the persons in
the network and now that I talk this
through 17 and 1 12 seconds passed and
pandas loaded all the data frames
concatenated them together and it says
that there are 8.9 million people in
this network so this is rather slow you
would be tempted to check your email or
write some messages so maybe spark will
be faster let's see so I will again run
this spark has started uh we also
explain to spark that the files have
headers we use the pipe as the delimiter
and it has to load it from the person
directory and it's loading and it's 11.7
seconds so it's slightly faster than
pandas because it can run on multiple
CPU cores so it can paralyze but it's
still rather slow let's see duck DB so
we have this magic duck DB loaded and we
can run uh this simple expression on
Duck DB that creates a table called
person from the CSV files note that we
didn't specify that it has to be a pipe
separator du DB will try to figure it on
its own and ddb takes roughly 1.6
seconds so more than 10 times faster
than uh pandas and about six times
faster than What spark was and you can
see that it did all the work because it
has the same number 8.9 million people
in the network and now that we have it
here we can run queries on it so this is
as I said roughly 9 million people and
you can run queries like selecting the
people who have a birthday and it is
kind of Snappy it's coming back to you
interactively you can ask questions
about the data and it will run
reasonably quickly and you can browse it
in the familiar Jupiter environment of
python okay so this was the loader part
of the demo let's continue with the rest
of the
talk um as I
said we have this fast CSV loader and it
doesn't only work on the social Network
person data set I ran a more
comprehensive Benchmark and on this
MacBook which I'm using for presenting I
managed to load CSV files up to 253 gabt
and the best thing about this is is that
it doesn't take a long time so it loads
that in less than 4 minutes which
amounts to more than 1 gigabyte of CSV
read from the disk pared turned into
data tables and then return into duck
DB's internal format so this is all very
Snappy for getting started once we get
started uh we may want to get uh more
data and run some queries well duck Deb
doesn't only support csvs it supports
all the important formats that are
popular in data science so it supports
the Apache Parky format it supports Json
files compressed versions of these files
Iceberg and ND Json and it has its own
format which is the duck DB file that we
use to persist on
disk it's very important that often the
data doesn't live on your laptop so ddb
can read from HTTP it can read from
Amazon S3 buckets Google cloud and it
can also hook up to a postgress database
and just use the tables there or a
sqlite database for that matter it's
really quite flexible in terms of the
data sources that it accepts and once
the data is in we can use the powerful
SQL quer language of course SQL is very
popular in the database word and we
selected a dialect of SQL that we
believe is one of the most reasonable
ones this is the pgra SQL dialect that
is supported by the pgra SQL database
and many tools that are available we
support the full dialect including
aggregations joins window functions
Common Table expression so it's not just
the core of SQL but
also uh quite a few of the more
sophisticated SQL features and we think
that SQL is a great language for doing
analytics but there is some room for
improvement there and uh I would like to
highlight in particular three of these
so going back to the demo we have this
person table in um the table is still
here we can see that we have uh just
five people selected that you can
observe but uh how about running a query
which takes the um most popular persons
the most popular first names and lists
us the five most popular first names
what I would write as a SQL practitioner
is I would say I'm interested in the
first name and I'm interested in how
popular that is so that would be a count
aggregation I name it as CNT for count
and then I would like to say it is
something that should be ordered by the
count descending and then run the query
and something I always forget is to
add the aggregation so SQL is always
complaining that if you do something
like count star you have to say Group by
correct so we can add this group
by and then SQL will be happy and it
will give us back the most popular first
name which is John and the second one is
a dot in this network the problem is
that this is something the machine could
figure it out and you're prone to forget
it forgetting it so if you would say
last name then you would have the same
issue and then you would have to come
here so something we added in Duck DB
was Group by all which says well take
all of the attributes that are here that
are not part of the aggregation and then
you can just run this and very simply
include uh all of these columns in the
aggregation so this is something that
people really appreciate it turns out
and other SQL vendors have already
copied this from Duck DB this is one of
the peak uh duck DB features that we
have another feature that we have is
that you often start a query
with select star and it turns out that
this is not really necessary you can
just say from person and select star
will be added automatically by the
system
so of course sometimes you do want to
select many of the attributes but maybe
here we would just like to have
everything except the creation date and
the email address of the people in a
traditional SQL system you would just
copy out the attribute names and then
you would start to enumerate ID first
name Etc but in Duck DB you can use the
exclude keyword and you can say I want
everything except the creation date and
the email address of the people and this
works very nicely you can see that now
the table basically fits a single screen
if I zoom out a bit it just removed
those two attributes and uh kept the
rest in the list
duck DB is also need for working with
nested data so this email attribute that
I have just removed is something that is
semicolon separated within the CSV file
you can see that it has this semicolon
because a single person can have
multiple email addresses well we would
like to sometimes take this apart and
analyze it and this is totally possible
we can use something called split for
splitting
the email
address like
so then we have a list and if you want
to unest that list we can use the unest
function and then we can see that this
person has five email addresses and this
is already a lot easier to work with in
subsequent queries so we try to make it
easy to also work with nested data in
SQL
a final thing that I think is really
great and this is by no means a dug DB
invention but this is something that
duck DB adopted from other systems is
Pivot and unpivot it turns out that in
many cases you have data like this this
is the population of big cities given in
thousand of people and you have Decades
of 2000 2010 and 2020 and it is
sometimes beneficial to turn this into
columns so you take the years and turn
them into columns there is an operation
for this called pivot this is already
supported in Microsoft Excel and other
products but people very rarely actually
use these well uh duck DB has this and
uh you can see that it is very simple
syntactically you just say pivot cities
on the year using the sum of population
and then it does the pivot
also you can unpivot so you can change
between this long table representation
and V table representation just by
running pivot and
unpivot okay so we are at a pi data
Meetup so let's talk about python but
first we would like to express our love
for python dgdb loves python we claim
that python is our primary API and
indeed we do our utmost to support all
the important features in our python
client
part of this integration is that we want
to make it easy to gradually integrate
with duck DB and to this end ddb can
read pandas data frames so dgdb
understands the binary format of the
pandas data frames because it runs in
process in the python process it can
actually see that area of the memory so
if you have something like my underscore
DF in this example then you can just
write your duck DB SQL queries saying I
want to select the average of this value
from mycore DF and it will give you back
a duck DB table that has the correct
answer
42.5 what's more you can then take this
answer and turn it back into a Punda
data frame by just saying DF parenthesis
and then you're back in pandas land so
this is all very easy and seamless and
unlike with most approaches that we have
seen here you do not have to create a
copy so this is called a zeroc copy
access ddb just sees the Panda's data
frame in the memory and operates
directly on that without doing any extra
unnecessary
steps we can also work with numpy arrays
numpy is of course very popular in
Python and it's processed by many of the
machine learning libraries you can take
a pandas data frame query it from Doc DB
and then fetch it using the fetch npy
function which will give give you back a
dictionary of nonp arrays and then you
can take the dictionary fetch value from
it like my array a has this array of 42
and 43 and then you can use numpy and p.
sum to work on it so this is again for
improved integration with existing uh
python
libraries we understand that not all of
the people use Python so doc DB is very
portable in fact we have a command line
client that you can run in the Shell on
the python and we have of course pip
install but we also have an r package
and we support more than 10 other
languages we have a Java client a Julia
client a rust client and so on so Doug
DB is
really very portable for all of these
languages and this is actually more
tricky than it seems in the first place
because now we have quite a
heterogeneous landscape of operating
systems and architectures we have Linux
which is absolutely dominating in the
server word we have Windows which is
quite dominating in the business word
still and we have Mac OS Which is
popular for desktop computers and we
have different architectures
x86 uh from Intel and AMD and we have
arm running on the Macintosh computers
in the Amazon Cloud and all the
smartphones and some Microsoft computers
as well so this can be quite tricky
especially if we multiply it with all
the
languages then it is sometimes da thing
because if you take this laptop and the
demo I have just shown that was python
apple and arm but if we talk to a data
scientist that works on Windows that may
be R windows and x86 so having support
for all of these combinations is quite a
large effort and we do our best to ship
all the pre-compiled binary packages so
that people can indeed do p install or
install those packages in R and just
work it immediately on their
computers so duck DB on its own is
already quite a powerful system but
there is always room for adding more
extensions because there are so many
formats and so many possible
Integrations that we have an extension
mechanism this allows you to Define
types Define your userdefined functions
Define more syntax elements for duck DB
new file formats new compression methods
and so on and in fact many of the
important features that I have shown are
already implemented as extensions in
main.db we have quite a few popular
extensions full text search for working
with natural text and geospatial for
working with geospatial data I have one
example for geospatial here here this
adds types that which allow you to model
maps by defining points and polygons and
it has functions like calculating
distances and once you have this it adds
all these userdefined functions to your
SQL and you can do things like
calculating the aial distance between
two points trivially in something like
the nework texi data
set so this seems good but what is Doc
DB actually used for and and the answer
may be a bit surprising one of the peak
use cases of duck DB is just saving cost
so people of course want to save the
cost of their development time and they
want to save the cost of them just
waiting and stirring their coffee until
the querer finishes and they also want
to save the cost of running a spar
cluster or working with a cloud data
warehouse so when the talk title says
the power of a data warehouse in your
python process this is something that we
mean and this is something that can
benefit in significant time and cost
savings and this deep integration that
we have with python and that I talked
about is something that allows you to
take an existing python script and
optimize it gradually so we don't expect
you to buy into duck DB and rewrite
everything in the form of duck DB tables
and duck DB SQL queries if only a single
part of your python script is slow
you're very welcome to try and use duck
DB to take that particular part and try
to run it faster maybe you will just use
duck DB for loading the csvs or maybe
you will just use it for a single
complicated joint operation it is
completely up to
you uh one particular use case that is
unique to duck DB and uh I would like to
mention is that it runs through web
assembly in browsers so you can go to
shell. dub. org and this will run in
browser so this may need a bit of
explanation because we already did the
Jupiter example but with the Jupiter
example the queries are typed in the
browser but run in a python process on
the background here the entire thing
runs in the browser you can take a phone
you can run duck DB on it and use the
shell and it will run within the phone's
integrated browser so this is something
that is thanks to ddb's extreme
portability and of course we don't
expect many end users to open a browser
and do complicated number crunching in
it but it's very useful for something
that's called a Last Mile analytics
which is you have some data somewhere
and you have processed it down to the
last 100 lines and then you would like
to visualize it but in the visualization
you have some filtering you have some
sorting Etc here you can use duck DB to
take that and run the final processing
step before you visualize it for the
user and this results in a very Snappy
user experience where you have a
dashboard that responds immediately to
your filtering ordering and other
operations so duck DB is of course an
open source software project but there
are a few organizations around it and
people sometimes ask us what all these
are about well duck DB is a project that
is under something called the duck DB
Foundation the found owns the Project's
intellectual property rights and allows
people to use it under the MIT
license there is a company where I also
work which is called du DB labs this is
the company that does most of the
development and provides commercial
support services for duck DB and there
is an American startup called mother
duck mother duck provides a serverless
platform that runs on Duck DB and it
implements something called hybrid query
execution where you have your duck DB in
your laptop but also you have mother
duck running on a server which can
potentially Run part of a complicated
query this is called hybrid query
execution and it's a novel approach to
running queries in a cloud data
warehouse and a local system in a hybrid
shared
fashion so if you found this interesting
then please give Duc DB a spin if you
don't really want to install anything
you can even go to Google collaboratory
ddb is pre-installed so you can just
start a new Google collab notebook say
import duck DB and get started with it
it's very easy and especially students
we found like working with this very
much because of the ease of the setup we
have a comprehensive documentation we
have both detailed reference for all our
functions and types and syntax and we
have guides on how one should use duct
DB it's now SP more than 800 pages so we
hope that whatever you're looking for is
in the docs if not just please reach out
so to sum up Duck DB is an inprocess
analytical data management systems it is
portable it is feature Rich it's fast
and it supports wide array of languages
but python has a special place in our
heart so if you're here uh you will
likely approach dgdb from python we have
an active online community so if you
would like to stay in touch join our
Discord follow us on X and just visit
our website so thank you very much and
uh don't forget to take some of our swag
so we have baseball caps and stickers as
merchandise for you thank you for being
very attentive thank
you so we have time for
Q&A uh let's start with the first row so
uh so thanks for the presentation it's
really interesting
project and it is something similar I
mean in SQL part with snowflake because
the snowflake has the many many features
that you describe so my question is
related to uh SQL part so um what about
the constraint like the primary keys on
the other constraint do it support it
and how it works do it
make some
automatic keys in some columns like in
Snowflake that's an excellent question
and I even have a slide for this I think
um so one of the things that people get
really surprised when using duck DB is
that you barely ever use any constraints
we support primary keys and we support
foreign keys but what they actually do
is they tend to make a workload slower
and the reason for that is that during
the loading you have to of course check
whether those constraints are being uh
adhered to by your data and during the
queries du DB does not really use any of
those constraints what ddb has and that
is built in and happens automatically is
something called zone maps which for
each of the block on the dis store the
minimum and the maximum value and it
turns out that for queries where you
look up a single ID that's usually
sufficient for queries where you scan
some sort of range that's usually a big
uh benefit and also sufficient so this
is counterintuitive but indexes are not
really used by Duc DB we have something
called Art indexes because in some
Corner cases it is indeed beneficial to
have primary Keys foreign key
constraints and unique constraints and
then you can have art indexes but only a
few perc of our workloads with high
selectivity queries use that I see thank
you and one more question
please um and um I really like the
feature with when you just can select
from the pandas uh variable so uh my
question is how it what is what about
performance how why I should use ddb
instead of pandas in that case cuz
because I thought if you select from the
pandas data structure the pandas should
select it more efficient because it is
the uh data structure they they are Crea
yes so how you handle this
into why your approach is better so the
main benefit that ddb gets is
parallelism so this laptop has 10 CPU
cores at its disposal so even if we do
the same thing as pandas which is uh
running on a single thread we are
approximately 10 times faster if we have
enough data to parallelize on so it is
mostly boiling down to parallelism and
then if you have subsequent joins
aggregations and other operations then
the vectorized crew execution model that
I have shown is also faster than what
pandas does and it doesn't run at the
risk of running out of memory which can
happen with
pandas than so the Glo Global
interpretator lock is doesn't affect um
the global interpretor lock doesn't
affect duck DB because its queries are
run in
C++ and uh we actually have some uh
further improvements on that so
we have a block post scheduled on how to
work around the global interpreter lock
on M that was something that was
implemented by ICU
and uh in general we are very much
looking forward to the global
interpreter log being dropped from the
next python version so that's something
that will of course help the user
defined functions run faster in
Python next
question okay seems like I got the mic
thanks for the talk uh just wanted to
ask what's the price to pay what's the
price it that I have to use SQL and then
until I learned your nice syntax I have
to stick to
postes um no uh I have many answers for
this so let's confess some of the
negatives if you use du DB on your
laptop you will not be able to
collaboratively work on the same data
set a cloud data warehouse is great if
you have a thousand data scientists
working on the same data set then it
makes sense to run it in the cloud if
you have a thousand data scientists then
you probably also have very Deep Pockets
to pay for the cloud data warehouse uh
the price to pay is also that if you
have really update heavy ver clads if
your data change changes frequently then
I would not really use du DB especially
if you have lots of deletes then it's
better if it resides in a transactional
system but we have thought about people
who want to gradually move away from
other systems we have a new prototype
called duck parkk and duck Park is
something that allows you to use the
familiar spark interface so duck spark
is a drop-in replacement for spark that
implements the P spark API it's
currently experimental but you can
already see that you build a pandas data
frame you turn it into a SP data frame
and you extend it with a column so this
seems very much like spark except if you
peek up this is actually a duck DB
package that provides something called
sparkk session so this is duck debing
under the hood but you can access it
through the
familiar spark calls and we also have
something called the duck DB relational
API the relational API is very similar
to the pandas API so you can run
operations like aggregate except filter
condition Etc so this is probably closer
to how most data scientists think about
data than SQL so you don't have to
embrace the entire postra SQL dialect
and the SQL way of thinking which we
acknowledge can be a big
blocker question in the
back uh thank you for the interesting
presentation uh two questions uh first
one about the support of a concept of a
stage where you can ideally load many
many multiple and homogeneous files into
a temporary structure that should be
then I don't know loaded like the
similar to snowflake stage and with its
all file format and flexibility does du
DP support or do you have plans for
adding support like similar to its
flexib similar to snowflakes flexibility
so what is the stage that you mentioned
stage is like a place where you can load
many files from a bucket with a prefix
with particular file formats Etc and
then you can proceed proceed with
loading from there like imagine 100
files or whatever more than that
homogeneous so the same structure
loading all of them into a single file
with a single
operation and proceeding from that table
if that makes sense so it snowflake has
the idea of stage right so all of the
duck DB uh load operators that we use
the CSV loader the park loader the Json
loader support the asterisk for Joker so
you can tackle multiple flies at once I
use this to load thousands of CSV files
with a single instruction if that's
homogeneous that is helpful you can of
course build your python script around
this and Tackle different data formats
and different sources one another on
after another and we have something
called a hi partition data source which
may be interesting for this um answer so
often the data is already partitioned
based on some sort of a system like the
date where the directory structuring
Calles the year and the month and uh we
also support
that okay next question because you had
two I think you said two questions yeah
one more guess yes go ahead but in the
unpivot section I noticed uh do you have
to explicitly mention column names in
the unpivoting operation or can you get
away with mentioning some kind of like a
I don't know indexing The Columns Etc CU
that's a pain sometimes if you have too
many columns that's a very good question
and uh it is something that surprisingly
boards really well with the
exclude uh
syntax yes you can combine them and it
makes perfect sense to do so so I
believe this is even mentioned in our
documentation so indeed you do not have
to spell out every single column you
just say you want all the columns to be
un pivoted on except on the ones that
you would like to keep as sort of the
key and then um ddb does the rest for
you
automatically indeed so we don't want to
make you do work that the computer can
do it for you so this is a what we call
the hasslefree
philosophy of du DB but yeah very nice
question all right uh more
questions
yeah presentation like uh suppose you
have like one terabyte or 5 terab of
data data so how Doc DB like like
handles this challenge cuz you compared
it with like uh cloud data warehouses
and don't you think it is a little bit
tricky to compare when we have a large
scale yeah yeah so I had a slide that I
just removed before this talk and it was
um kind of a bonus round uh on the CSU
loader performance so this MacBook has a
one tbte disc so it was not enough but I
took another MacBook and I ran this uh
experiment on it this was 2.6 terab of
CSV file and it took about 45 minutes to
load and it resulted in a 600 gigabytes
disk file uh in Duck DB's native
format I
think very few people have actually this
amount of data um there is a point where
indeed you start running out of
resources with duck DB if you have 5 to
10 terabytes of data I would first try
mother duck that does a really nice job
in complimenting duck DB and if you have
maybe 100 terabytes of data then it's
definitely something where it makes
perfect sense to use spark or to use
snowflake or these cloud data warehouses
so they definitely have their use case
but if you just have up to a few hundred
gigabytes then duck DB is perfect for
you all right
questions yeah yeah that's again me uh
just wanted to ask so let's say I took
the data loaded did my magic and
then if I want to and it wasn't small
mhm um
then I do I export to something raw give
someone else to look load again or is
there an option to keep it loaded
somewhere um it is and it is this DB
file or du DB so it's a single format
that contains all the tables and this is
portable between different architectures
and different languages so if I create
this file on the MacBook and send it to
someone with Windows and R they will be
able to read the same file and we are
currently working on finalizing this
format so it will be readable with
backwards compatible releases of duck DB
in the next decade hopefully so that's
something we would like to achieve and
the other thing that people really like
to use is just to say export database
and that will give you a bunch of parket
files and that's great because that's
very widely ingested format then you can
take it into spark take it into
Snowflake and other systems so indeed
after a lengthy ingestion process it
makes sense to keep a more uh portable
binary format like park or do DB's own
format okay maybe one last question from
from the the front
row uh one question regarding supporting
of Aras uh columns yeah uh cuz in my
previous company there were a problem
like we are were storing in column
feature vectors of person for examp
and searching through the this R in
standard SQL database it it was really
hard and painful what about your
database is it fast looking through the
ri elements I mean yes so we have
realized that Vector databases are now a
big thing thank to to machine learning
natural language processing and other AI
Solutions and we are working very hard
to give something called a fixed length
list support and that will will improve
the performance when you are looking uh
for vectors or you're running operations
on vectors so this is something that is
already in Duck DB but it's not in its
final form yet it will be faster in the
near
future cool um thank you yeah thank you
so
[Applause]
much